♪ ♪
>> Brian: WHERE DOES THE TIME
GO, NOW TIME FOR "FINAL EXAM"
WHERE WE SEE WHICH NEWS
ATTENTION TO CURRENT EVENTS,
TONIGHT WE CLOSE THE 2017
ADDITION WITH A SPECIAL YEAR
REVIEW.
THE QUESTIONS WILL EXPAND THIS
PAST WEEK, BUT ALL OF 2017 IS ON
THE TABLE.
THESE CONTESTANTS ARE REALLY
BRIGHT, LISA BOOTHE PLAYING
HERSELF AS LISA BOOTHE, AND MARK
STEYN, WHO ONCE HOSTED THE SHOW
EARLIER IN THE WEEK.
ARE YOU GUYS READY?
>> I TRIED TO GET YOU TO POOL
DONNA BRAZILE, AND HE WOULD NOT
DO IT.
>> Brian: I WOULD NOT GIVE YOU
THE ANSWERS, YOU KNOW WHY, LISA,
THEY KNOW THAT I WOULD BREAK.
BUZZERS.
I'M GOING TO ASK THEM QUESTIONS,
TO REVIEW THE RULES, AND THE
FINISH THE QUESTION BEFORE -- IT
IS NOT LIKE FAMILY FEUD.
YOU LOSE A POINT, IF YOU GET IT
RIGHT, YOU GET A POINT, AND THE
BEST OF THE FIVE QUESTIONS GETS
STOPPED THAT FIGHT AND SCRAPED
WHAT WAS LEFT WITH YOU OFF OF
THE CAMPUS.
SO AS LONG AS IT IS NOT A
BRIAN KILMEADE SCENARIO.
WHEN I THOUGHT IF I DID THE BEST
I COULD IT WOULD BE OKAY, MARK.
OKAY, YOU ARE OFF, SO THESE GUYS
ARE ON, CAST YOUR MIND BACK TO
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR, YOU
WERE CHILDREN THEM.
THERE WAS A BIG MESS UP AT THE
OSCARS WITH THE PRESENTERS FOR
THE BEST PICTURE REGARDING --
WAIT UNTIL I FINISH THE QUESTION
WAIT UNTIL I FINISH THE QUESTIO
QUESTION.
>> A TECHNICALITY.
>> Brian: WHICH TWO ACTING
LEGENDS WERE LEFT RED-FACED
AFTER READING THE WRONG CARD?
>> HAVE YOU FINISHED A QUESTION?
FAYE DUNAWAY AND WARREN BEATTY?
>> Brian: LET'S WATCH.
>> THE MOST EMBARRASSING MISTAKE
IN AWARD SHOW HISTORY, EVERYBODY
IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> WARREN BEATTY, FAYE DUNAWAY,
BONNIE AND CLYDE COMING OUT
THERE AND THEY ROBBED A BANK OF
>> Brian: YOU ARE CORRECT,
SIR.
1-0 MARK!
>> I DO NOT WATCH AWARD SHOWS.
>> COME SHANNON FROM NOW ON.
WHEN EXCUSES AFTER YOU GET IT
WRONG MAKE IT ALL THE WORSE.
THANK YOU FOR ALMOST GETTING IT
WRONG, MARK, PLAYING AND PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE RULES.
DICTATOR KIM JONG UN TRADING A
NEW NICKNAME FOR KIM AT THE
UNITED NATIONS, WHAT IS THAT
NICKNAME?
>> ROCKET MAN.
>> Brian: LET'S WATCH.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THAT THE
U.S. MAY HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
QUOTE TOTALLY DESTROY
NORTH KOREA, AND HE CALLED OUT
THE DICTATOR KIM JONG UN.
>> ROCKET MAN IS ON A SUICIDE
MISSION FOR HIMSELF AND FOR HIS
REGIME.
>> ROCKET MAN OBVIOUSLY THE
ELTON JOHN SONG, I DON'T KNOW
WHY ANYBODY IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA IS COMPLAINING, BECAUSE HE
IS CALLING, LIKE YOU SAID A
NICKNAME.
>> DOTARD IS THE SONG.
>> Brian: JUDGES, 1-1.
WE MOVE TO QUESTION NUMBER
THREE, MARK AND LISA STILL
PLAYING THEMSELVES IN THIS GAME.
>> PLAYING OURSELVES POORLY.
>> Brian: DONALD TRUMP SEND A
MAINSTREAM MEDIA INTO A COMPLETE
MELTDOWN THIS YEAR.
[LAUGHTER]
AFTER TWEETING THAT IT COULD BE
THE MOST FAMOUS TYPO OF ALL
TIME, WHAT WAS THAT TYPO?
>> Brian: IS A COVE HEAVY?
>> IF YOU WANT ME TO SAY HOW TO
PRONOUNCE US, WE HAVE NO IDEA.
>> WE ARE GOING TO LET YOU MAKE
THE CALL THIS MORNING, THAT IS
THE GLITCH, .
>> Brian: CUFF FA, YOU SPEAK
FLUENT FRENCH.
>> DESPITE THE PRESS.
>> THIS IS THE BEST ONE YET.
YOU ARE HUNDRED% RIGHT, LISA
HOW COULD HE NOT JUST SAY YOU
MADE A MISTAKE?
>> IT IS A GREAT WORD, THE WORD
OF THE YEAR.
>> Brian: OKAY, MARK STEYN.
>> HE CAN PROBABLY DO IT, HE IS
VERY SMART.
>> Brian: YOU TWO ARE STARTING
TO BUG ME.
QUESTION NUMBER FOUR, A
MULTIPLE-CHOICE QUESTION,
HILLARY CLINTON EMBARKED ON THE
WORLD'S LONGEST BOOK TOUR AND
SHE EXPLAINED THE GREAT DETAIL
SHE HAS BEEN DRINKING A LOT OF
ALCOHOL TO DEAL WITH THE STRESS.
WHAT IS HILLARY'S GO TO DRINK OF
CHOICE?
IS IT PINA COLADA, BUT HE
>> CHARDONNAY.
>> Brian: IS IT CHARDONNAY AND
CUSTOMER GO TO THE TAPE.
>> I WILL NOT LIVE, CHARDONNAY
>> YES, I HAD MY FAIR SHARE OF
CHARDONNAY.
>> TRYING TO CALM MYSELF DOWN
AND YOU KNOW, MY SHARE OF
>> WHO DOES NOT LIKE CHARDONNAY?
>> IT IS A VERY POLITICAL TOOL.
>> Brian: YOU ARE 100% RIGHT,
CHARDONNAY, LET'S CHECK THE
SCORES NOW, 2-2.
WE HAVE GOTTEN THE RIGHT ANSWER
EACH AND EVERY TIME, SO THIS
WILL BE THE TIEBREAKER IF I HAVE
THIS CORRECT.
LET'S GO.
FINAL QUESTION.
BACK IN THE SUMMER, THE ESPN
FACED A FIRESTORM AFTER IT
PULLED AN ANNOUNCER FROM CALLING
A UNIVERSITY OF VIRGINIA
FOOTBALL GAME, THE REASON, ESPN
DID NOT LIKE HIS NAME, WHAT WAS
THE ANNOUNCER'S NAME?
>> ROBERT TO LEE.
>> Brian: LISA BOOTHE SAYS
ROBERT LEE, ANNOUNCER JOT THAT
DOWN, I WILL ROLL THE TAPE.
>> A FOX NEWS ALERT, THEIR
REPORTS TONIGHT TO THAT ESPN HAS
PULLED A FOOTBALL ANNOUNCER FROM
UPCOMING GAME BECAUSE OF HIS
NAME.
WHICH IS ROBERT TO LEAVE.
THE TWIST, LEE IS AN ASIAN MAN,
BUT I AM NOT EMBARRASSED THAT
ALISA HAS DEFEATED MARK STEYN BY
A FINAL SCORE OF 3-2!
>> CAN I THINK PEOPLE FOR THIS
MOMENT.
I WANT TO THINK MY PARENTS FOR
BELIEVING IN ME?
>> WHAT ABOUT YOUR AGENT?
>> OH, YES, EVERYONE.
IS THIS LIKE THE OSCARS, DID YOU
READ OUT THE WRONG WINNER?
>> AND I STILL CONSIDER MYSELF
THE SECOND WORST CONTESTANT